guess what we've got some exciting news
you can now text the minimalist podcast
your questions nine three seven two oh
two four six five four we'll do our best
to answer as many of your questions as
possible but even if we don't answer
them on air
we might even text you back Ryan and I
both get that text it comes right to our
phones nine three seven two oh two four
six five four enjoy the show
dark mode wants to know how do you
overcome impostor syndrome I think we're
all imposters to an extent I mean it's
what I mean by that is is as one of the
minimalists like I still want to buy
stuff I mean I still have impulses it's
you know it's it's uh I remember when we
first started the website I felt
sometimes that like the imposter police
we're gonna come up and be like you're
not a true minimalist you own you own
more than 50 things and you know
ultimately if you're if you're being
congruent with with who you are and
you're being genuine even acting as if
someone you want to be so you know I
think about I'm thirty I just turned
thirty eight years old to think about my
40 year old self and you know who do I
want to be at 40 and I try to act as if
I am that you know ideal 40 year old
self I don't think I'll actually get to
a hundred percent the perfect 40 year
old person that I want to be but I
certainly will inch closer and closer
towards it and the more you can do that
the more genuine you do start to feel I
mean now I don't feel nearly as much of
an imposter but you know I fly in
airplanes and that bothers me I don't
know the alternative to that what am I
going to sail on the ship to go you know
it's speak somewhere I mean it's it's a
there's not a good alternative Soviet
submarine minimalist submarine but I
think what you're were you talking about
here to a certain extent is lowering
your expectations that's why we often
feel like a boss an imposter is is we're
trying to live up to everyone else's
expectations by the way they're almost
always conflicting expectations too
right if there are ten different people
you don't want to be an imposter toward
but then they have ten different
expectations so you can lower your
expectations you can raise your personal
standards
and lowering your expectations raising
your standards I think is a recipe to to
live a more congruent life if you're
living a more congruent life you're not
gonna feel like an imposter yeah I don't
have much more to add I mean I feel like
an imposter from time to time gonna have
to take on things I don't know how to do
and I feel like I'm supposed to know how
to do those things the other thing
that's interesting is I feel like you
can feel like an imposter and the other
way too which is I used to know how to
do some things that I can't do anymore
because my like those skills of
atrophied because now I lead a company
versus like before when I started it was
just me I was making all the stuff
myself no I don't do that as much and
when I have to go back to do that I'm
pretty rusty so it's funny that you can
feel like an imposter
at something used to be really good at
but you're not anymore just I give
everyone permission to feel that way
like you don't need to not feel that way
it happens it's fine it's like an it in
some ways it's it's it's a it's a good
stand-in for Drive I mean the fact that
that like if you feel like you're
imposter you probably want to maybe be
better at what you're doing and that's
okay too but like it's it's it's all
like you said it's all about
expectations and it's fine and you're
gonna feel that you'll never gonna get
rid of that I think most people probably
never do and it's totally fun it's
natural normal feeling to have
you